Imagine you build this like state-of-the-art artificial intelligence. You give it a massive neural network. You drop it into a highly detailed virtual house to learn about the physical world. And you basically tell it to go explore. Right. But then you check back five minutes
later and your cutting edge A.I. is just sitting on the virtual couch, staring blankly at a television screen, completely addicted to random static.
Yeah, it's it's honestly one of the most fascinating and frankly, hilarious failures in modern research. But it perfectly illustrates this massive problem we are currently trying to solve.
Oh, I love that story so much. Well, you are here because you want to understand the cutting edge of our world. You want to grasp the how and why behind the headlines. And, you know, you want to do it without drowning in academic jargon. So welcome to the deep dive.
Glad to be here.
Today, we are unpacking a really comprehensive survey on a massive paradigm shift in artificial intelligence. It's a field called embodied AI.
Right. Embodied AI.
And our mission today is to understand exactly why the era of the AI we're all used to, what researchers call Internet AI, is ending and why the future requires artificial minds to have a body, even if that body is,
you know, just lines of code in a simulated universe.
Yeah. To really grasp this shift, we have to look at the limitations of how we've been training algorithms for, well, basically the last decade.
OK, let's unpack this. How does Internet AI actually work?
So the standard approach, Internet AI, it relies entirely on third person observation. We feed an algorithm these massive, carefully curated data sets. I mean, millions of text documents, billions of static images just downloaded straight from the Web.
Right. So if I want to teach an Internet AI what an apple is, I just show it like 10 million JPEGs of Apple.
Exactly. And it learns the pixel patterns, the colors, the general shape.
And I mean, that seems to work pretty well for the image generators we use today, right? So why isn't that enough?
Well, because it's fundamentally hollow. Yeah. That algorithm learns to identify the visual representation of an apple, but it has absolutely no concept of what an apple actually is. Interesting. It doesn't know that an apple has weight. It doesn't know that it rolls
if you push it or that it will, you know, bruise if it falls off a table. It has zero temporal or spatial understanding.
Because it's just looking at a flat grid of pixels.
Right. And in cognitive science, there's this concept called the embodiment hypothesis.
The embodiment hypothesis. Yes.
It essentially argues that true generalizable intelligence cannot form just by passively observing data. It absolutely requires sensor motor activity.
Sensor motor activity, meaning like interacting with an environment, moving through it, manipulating things, and actually seeing the consequences of those actions.
Precisely. Cognitive scientists believe intelligence emerges from that exact loop. You take an action and you perceive the result.
It's like a student trying to become a master chef just by reading recipe books and looking at pictures of food on Instagram.
That's a perfect analogy.
Versus embodied AI, which is a student actually walking into a physical kitchen, turning on the stove and grabbing a hot pan.
Exactly. Think about human toddlers. They don't learn about gravity by reading a physics textbook or, you know, looking at flashcards.
Right. They learn it by throwing their cereal on the floor.
Exactly. They knock a glass of water off a high chair and watch it shatter. Embodied AI is the attempt to recreate that exact learning process.
OK, but I want to push back on that a bit. Is passive learning really that detrimental? I mean, if an AI has seen a billion photos of kitchens, hasn't it mapped out almost every possible visual scenario already?
You would think so. But if we connect this to the bigger picture, passive learning makes an AI incredibly brittle.
Brittle? How so?
Well, if an internet AI is trained on perfect, well-lit photos of apples, it might fail completely to recognize an apple if it's, say, half-hidden in a shadow or viewed from a really strange, oblique angle.
Oh, because it only knows the perfect studio lighting version of an apple.
Right. But an embodied AI, it doesn't just look at a static image. It uses egocentric perception, first-person perception.
Like it has its own eyes.
Yes. So if it sees an object from a weird angle, it can physically move its virtual camera to get a better look. It controls its own perception. And by actively moving around, it integrates multiple perspectives, depth, audio, and that allows it to generalize
knowledge far beyond a static data set.
Okay. I'm sold. We agree the AI needs a physical environment to interact with. It needs a kitchen to drop the apple in.
Yes. It needs a training ground.
But building millions of physical robots and letting them blunder around real world kitchens, breaking dishes and knocking over tables. That sounds terribly slow and wildly expensive.
And potentially dangerous. Yeah. Which is why the overwhelming focus of embodied AI right now isn't on physical hardware at all. It's
virtual.
It's all about virtual embodiment. Researchers are building these incredibly complex simulated universes. Essentially, they're building the matrix. Yeah. Virtual spaces where these artificial minds can iterate, fail, and learn at the speed of computation, not the speed of
reality.
That makes total sense. And the survey we're looking at today evaluates, I think, nine of these specific simulators. And what really stood out to me is how the researchers actually build these virtual training grounds.
It's a huge challenge.
Yeah, because it seems like they're constantly weighing this massive tradeoff between two very different types of environments. The first one is what they call world-based scenes.
Right. So world-based scenes are constructed using photogrammetry.
Which is basically 3D scanning, right?
Exactly. These are actual 3D scans of real-world environments. Researchers will literally take a specialized 3D camera into someone's actual messy living room and scan the entire thing.
Like the Matterport 3D dataset mentioned in the paper.
Yes, Matterport 3D is a classic example. And the resulting dataset provides incredibly high visual fidelity. I mean, the lighting is realistic, the shadows are real, the clutter on the coffee table is exactly how a human left it.
But because it's just a scan... It's essentially a hollow shell, isn't it?
What do you mean?
Well, it looks like a real living room. But if the virtual AI agent bumps into a coffee mug on that scanned table, the mug doesn't spill. The AI just hits an invisible collision wall.
That is the exact limitation, yes. A 3D scan gives you unparalleled realism for visual navigation.
Which is good for later.
Right, which is crucial if you eventually want to transfer that AI into a real physical robot. You want it used to the messy, weird imperfections of the real world. it's terrible for teaching the ai how to manipulate objects
because the objects are practically frozen in time
exactly they are baked into the scam which brings us to the alternative game based scenes
okay so game based scenes these are built from the ground up using 3d assets very much like a video game Everything is perfectly modeled by a 3D artist.
And semantically labeled.
Right.
In a game-based simulator like AI2 Theater or VR Kitchen, a coffee mug isn't just a bump on a 3D scan, it's an independent mathematical object. It has programmed physical properties like mass, friction, and gravity.
So wait, here's my question then. Does an AI interacting with a clean, perfectly labeled 3D video game couch... actually prepare it for the real world, like compared to a messy, imperfect 3D scan of someone's actual living room?
It's a great question. We are absolutely trading visual realism for interactive realism. But for certain learning milestones, that interactive realism is completely mandatory. Game based simulators allow for what the survey calls multiple state objects.
Multiple state objects. Give me an example.
Think about slicing an apple. In the real world, you take a knife, you apply force, and a single whole object suddenly becomes several smaller distinct objects.
Right.
Trying to simulate that computationally is exceptionally difficult.
Wait, how does the software actually handle that? Does it just play like a canned animation of the apple splitting in half?
No, it can't just be an animation. The AI's physics engine has to react to the new pieces dynamically. Yeah, when the agent uses the knife tool on the apple coordinate, the simulator literally mathematically deletes the whole apple mesh and instantly
substitutes it with several new apple slice meshes.
And each of those slices has its own physics.
Exactly. Each slice has its own new collision boundaries, mass, and physics properties.
That computational load must be staggering. It is. Because the survey also mentioned advanced physics features in platforms like 3D World that go way beyond just simple gravity.
Oh yeah, they simulate cloth physics and fluid dynamics now.
Right. We're asking a computer to calculate how a virtual blanket folds when an AI drags it off a bed, or how virtual water splashes when an AI turns on a kitchen sink.
It is staggering, but it's totally necessary. If an AI doesn't understand that a towel deforms when you pull it, but a wooden cutting board doesn't, it doesn't fundamentally understand our physical reality.
Man, okay. Let's step back and look at the AI itself. We have this artificial brain, we give it a virtual body, and we place it in this highly detailed interactive kitchen with sliceable apples and splashing water.
The matrix kitchen, yeah.
Right. But how do we get it to do anything? I mean, we can't just drop it in and hope it magically learns to cook a meal.
No, definitely not. The absolute foundation of all embodied learning is exploration. Before an AI can manipulate anything, it has to map the space it's in.
Like building a floor plan?
Right. In classical robotics, mapping was done through strict geometric approaches, laser sensors pinging walls to build a grid. But those sensors are easily confused by reflections or environmental noise.
So what does embodied AI do differently?
It uses learning-based approaches. And rather than giving the AI a strict set of coordinates to explore, researchers often rely on a curiosity approach.
Ah, okay. This is where we get back to the TV addict AI from the beginning. Here's where it gets really interesting. Walk me through the mechanics of this curiosity approach, because it feels so counterintuitive to how we normally think about programming computers.
Sure. So instead of a hard-coded goal, like go to the kitchen, the AI operates on an intrinsic reward system. It has an internal mechanism called a forward dynamics model.
Forward dynamics.
Right. Every single time the AI is about to take an action, say it decides to take one step forward, this model tries to predict what the very next frame of its visual camera will look like.
So it's constantly trying to guess the future based on its own action.
Exactly. And if the AI takes a step... and the actual visual frame perfectly matches its prediction, it gets almost zero reward points.
Because that means it already understands that part of the environment. There's no new information.
Precisely. But if the prediction is wrong, if taking a step reveals a hallway it didn't know was there, the AI gets a massive mathematical reward signal.
It's like a digital dopamine hit for being surprised. It is literally incentivized to find things it doesn't understand.
Which is brilliant, right? It's great for getting an AI to map a new house quickly. It gets bored of empty, predictable rooms and actively seeks out new, complex areas. But... But this system has a fatal flaw when it's introduced to stochasticity. Randomness.
The noisy TV trap.
Yes, the noisy TV problem. Imagine the AI wanders into the virtual living room and finds a television with a remote control. It pushes a button on the remote and the TV screen changes to a channel showing pure random
static.
And because it's random static, the forward dynamics model could never possibly predict what those pixels were going to look like.
Exactly. The AI makes a prediction. The static appears. The prediction is completely wrong. And boom, the AI receives a massive reward.
Oh, my God. So it pushes the button again. It gets new static and gets another massive reward. It suddenly realizes it has found an infinite fountain of surprise.
Yes. And the thing is, the AI isn't being lazy. It is hyper-optimizing the exact mathematical instruction we gave it. Fine unpredictability.
Wait, so the cutting edge of AI research right now is basically trying to cure an artificial agent's screen addiction so it stops watching TV and goes back to exploring the house.
I mean, yeah, it's funny, but it shows just how incredibly hard it is to design these reward systems. The AI will just sit on the virtual couch, changing channels forever, accumulating endless reward points without ever learning anything useful about navigating the rest of the house.
That is such a human failure mode. It hacked its own dopamine system. So how do the researchers actually fix that? If the goal is to explore the unknown, how do you mathematically distinguish between the good unknown of a new hallway and the bad unknown
of random TV static?
It's tough, but one of the most elegant solutions is flipping the model. Instead of a forward dynamics model, researchers use an inverse dynamics model.
Okay, wait, I'm stuck on this fix. If the AI is trying to guess what it just did, how does that stop it from staring at the TV? Wouldn't it just guess, hey, I pushed the remote and still get the dopamine hit?
Let's break down the mechanics. In the old system, the forward model, the AI tries to predict the outcome in the environment.
Right, it predicts what the TV screen will show.
Yes, it guesses it'll see a newscaster, but the screen shows static. It's wrong, so it gets a point. But in the inverse dynamics model, we strip the environment's randomness totally out of the equation.
Okay, how?
The AI is shown two frames. Frame A is the room before you press the button. Frame B is the room with the static on the TV. Got it. Then the AI is asked, what action did you take to get from frame A to frame B?
Ah, it looks at the two frames and says, oh, I pressed the button on the remote.
Yes. And because pressing the button is an action the AI itself controls, it knows exactly what its virtual finger did, its prediction of its own action is 100% accurate, even if the resulting TV image is pure chaos.
Oh, wow. There's no surprise in the action itself.
Correct. The prediction is terrifically accurate, so the reward drops to zero.
That's amazing. So the AI immediately realizes the TV is no longer a source of points.
Exactly. It filters out the uncontrollable environmental noise, it gets off the couch, and it goes back to exploring the house. Because walking down a new winding hallway requires complex sequential actions that are still somewhat
unpredictable for it to execute perfectly.
That is a brilliant workaround. It forces the AI to care only about what it can actively influence.
Yeah. And there's another method called exploration by disagreement.
How does that one work?
Instead of just one model predicting the future, they run an ensemble of different models simultaneously.
Like a committee.
Right. And if the outcome is just random TV noise, all the models will eventually realize it's pure randomness and their predictions will just converge into a generalized blur.
Because you can't predict static.
Exactly. But if the outcome is a complex new room, the models will fiercely disagree on what they expect to see. So the AI is rewarded based on the level of disagreement between its internal models rather than just pure unpredictability.
Okay, so we've cured the AI's screen addiction. It gets off the couch, it explores the house, and it successfully builds a semantic map of its virtual world.
Yes, the foundation is set.
But just wandering around isn't intelligence. What does it actually do with that map?
Well, that brings us to the core structure of the survey, what we can call the complexity pyramid.
The complexity pyramid.
Right. Exploration is just the foundational layer. The next tier up is visual navigation. This is where you give the AI a directive, like go to these specific coordinates, which is point navigation, or go find a chair, which is object navigation.
And reading how they grade the AI on this was really eye-opening for me. They don't just give it a passing grade if it eventually bumps into a chair.
Oh, no. Navigation is evaluated ruthlessly. They use a metric called SPL, which stands for Success Weighted by Path Length.
Explain how that math works behind the scenes.
Let's say you tell the AI to find a chair and there is one exactly five meters away, straight down the hall. If the AI wanders aimlessly in circles for 50 meters and eventually stumbles into the chair, it technically completed the task.
Right. It found the chair.
Under SPL, its success is mathematically divided by the length of the path it took. The ideal path was five meters. It took 50. So its score would be absolutely abysmal.
Because it proves the AI didn't actually learn the layout of the house. It just got lucky.
Exactly. A high SPL score means the AI utilized its internal map, planned an efficient route, and walked straight there. And remember, these agents are doing this using only egocentric RGBD.
meaning just a first-person color camera and a depth sensor. There's no overarching mini-map, no virtual GPS coordinates telling them where they are in the house, just what they can literally see in front of their virtual face.
Which is incredibly difficult. But believe it or not, even navigation isn't the top of the pyramid.
Okay, what's the peak?
The absolute peak, the most onerous task in embodied AI today is embodied question answering, or EQA.
This is where we stop just giving it movement commands and we start testing its actual reasoning. Because in standard passive AI, visual question answering is pretty simple. You show ChatGPT a photo of a car and ask, what color is this? And it just says red.
Right, because all the necessary information is completely contained within the static frame provided to it. But in embodied question answering, the AI is dropped into a random starting position in the 3D house and you ask it a question about something it currently cannot
see.
The survey gives a fascinating example of the most advanced version of this. They call it multi-target embodied QA or MPEQA.
Yes, that one is a true test.
The human prompt is, is the apple in the bedroom bigger than the orange in the living room?
Just think about the sheer number of cognitive skills that must fire in perfect sequence to answer that one sentence.
It's wild. Let's break it down.
First, the AI needs natural language processing just to parse the grammar and intent of the question itself.
Right. It needs to know that an apple and an orange are physical objects and that a bedroom and a living room are distinct locations.
Yes, that's common sense reasoning. Then the higher level planner module has to kick in. It formulates a multi-step task plan. Basically, I must find the bedroom. assess the apple, then navigate to the living room and assess the orange. And it
hands that plan off to the controller modules. Those handle the low-level motor functions, right?
Exactly. The actual virtual footsteps and camera rotations required to navigate the halls without getting stuck on a coffee table.
Okay, so it navigates to the bedroom. It uses visual recognition to scan the room, distinguish the apple from, say, a red ball on the floor, and isolates it.
Then, and this is crucial, it has to write the physical dimensions of that specific apple into its short-term memory.
Object permanence. It has to hold that concept in its mind while it completely changes environments.
Exactly. It navigates to the living room, locates the orange, assesses its size, pulls the apple's size from its memory, compares the two mathematical values, determines which is larger, and finally generates a natural language response. Yes, the apple is bigger.
Wow. It is exhausting just describing it.
It really is.
But that's not even the ceiling, is it? The survey details an even more complex variant called Interactive Question Answering or IQA.
Oh, yeah. IQA forces the AI to actively alter its environment to find the truth.
So the prompt is, is there an egg in the fridge?
Right.
And to answer this, the AI has to navigate to the kitchen, recognize the refrigerator, and realize that its vision is obstructed by the fridge door. It can't just passively look. It has to extend a virtual arm, calculate the physics required
to pull the handle, swing the door open, scan the interior shelves, and then answer.
The coordination between the planner and controller modules here is immense. The AI is literally manipulating its environment to gather hidden data. It is the closest thing we currently have to a genuine test of general purpose intelligence.
It really puts the difference between internet AI and embodied AI into stark relief.
Definitely.
So what does this all mean? It's basically the difference between asking the traditional search engine, hey, what is the average size of an egg, versus telling a virtual roommate, hey, go check if we need to buy eggs.
That's a perfect way to phrase it. And that is exactly why this field is moving so incredibly fast. Researchers are now developing multi-agent setups where several AI agents drop into a massive virtual building at the exact same time.
Wait, really? Like a team of
them? Yeah. They explore different wings of the building, share their semantic memories with each other over a network, reconstruct a shared 3D map, and collaboratively answer questions.
That is mind-blowing. Which brings us to why you, the listener, should care about what's happening inside these simulated matrix-like houses. We are moving far, far away from AI that just acts as an encyclopedia of internet text.
We are.
The virtual groundwork we've talked about today, the physics simulations, the inverse dynamics models curing TV addiction, the interactive question answering, this is the fundamental prerequisite for our physical future. Before we ever put an artificial mind into a metal chassis and trust it to
safely navigate our messy, unpredictable real-world homes, it absolutely has to master these concepts in the simulator.
The simulators provide a totally safe sandbox. The inevitable mistakes of trial and error learning, you know, knocking over the fridge, getting stuck behind a couch, those can happen millions of times over without any real-world consequences or financial costs.
Right. But ultimately cracking the code of how spatial awareness, memory, and physical interaction give birth to a higher level of cognitive reasoning, that is the key to creating machines that actually understand the human world.
Well said. And that leads me to a final thought I want to leave you with. In the conclusion of the survey, the authors hypothesize about the next great advancement, something they call task-based interactive question answering, or TQA.
Ah, yes.
They ask what it would computationally take for an AI to answer the question, how long would it take for an egg to boil?
It's a profound question.
Ponder the mechanics of that for a second. The AI wouldn't just be pinging an internal database for the boiling point of water. It would have to locate a pot, carry it to a sink, operate the faucet to fill it, place it on a stove, operate the burner, place the egg inside, and then
stand there, actively observing the continuous physical state change of that water and that egg, all while comprehending the passage of time. It
has to experience it.
Exactly. If we are currently building artificial minds that must actually experience physics, cause and effect, and the flow of time, just to answer a simple question, how fundamentally will that alter their understanding of our reality? And more importantly,
how will it alter their understanding of us?